ora os saldos é mais um vídeo e hoje vou
cidade que fazer uma besta do popular
muito por cima daquela do jogo ação
excluir o tempo está no bis cris são
vocês vão lá ver se imagens devo
testemunhar igualzinho uma vez que as
imagens não estão a escala é tão boa lá
o tutorial passo a passo e foi ninguém é
no entanto pinhais procure ao primeiro
quais têm mais de 90 da população com a
ajuda de uma cola button é justa a
imagem muito bem e recorte usando um
x-ato e uma régua
mas atenção se forem crianças peçam
ajuda o duto o mesmo certeza que nos vai
importar do chitato ninguém as linhas
usando uma régua ou então podem fazer
isso na borda da mesa estiveram muito
bem é só retirar o papel para não
atrapalhar pois o quarto retângulo
utilizando outra vez um x-ato ea régua
no final tem que tirar a papel
quadriculado que cortem o circo usando
uma tesoura é claro que é mais fácil
faça o mesmo para outra folha do tempo a
atenção aqui a orientação da população
não pode ser sentido no trimestre e
agora como você já deve estar a
adivinhar é só colar tudo muito bem
recortar usando um x-ato uma régua e
para os circos usar uma tesoura mas a
opção não tirem é quarto papel
quadriculado este módulo
depois para cortar tudo à moda dos
clipes como é que vocês estão vendo aqui
agora e fui os pontos instalados nos
modos
corta em dois pedaços do potengi picolé
o cumprimento do retângulo do modo que
você só obtiveram esquerda corta e mais
dois de largura destratando
collen o modo indicado no vídeo estou
usarem uma cola rápida é o confronto só
um kadim pacientes eca machado vocês
podem usar outro cola qualquer 44 dos
índios do centro extremidades pelo ipca
e colo de uma filha no colo indicado no
vídeo foi isso por nicola na parte
frontal coloca um ponto ligeiramente
mais alto que essa pilha agora
introduzir na caixa e vai ser no
livramento se andar é a altura certa por
um elástico a força do rosa cruz pouco
vai depender do elástico não convém que
usa e um bastão forte estou usar aqui um
elástico que usar pelas costuras
depois claro elástico com um bastão cola
e faixinha caixa corta embutindo a
largura da caixa e cola no lugar
assinalado hoje o cumprimento destes
dois pelo times subiram para fazer
obtive ofício do esporte em ver a mais
desses dois pilotos mas joaquim fica
sobreposto ao plantel inter força
agora vou precisar de um pontinho está a
usar aqui um poder sendo um campinho de
churrasco vocês podem usar o fósforo
ontem um convite a que os prudentes
nesse dia eu vou fazer cut usando um fio
qualquer um pode usar o ter fio dental
feito isso vamos lá em cima do povo
inteiro força mas aqui o sistema agora
por cima ficar mais eficiente muscular
um pedacinho de elástico em cima do punk
imóvel e se irá fazer com culpa o tempo
fique sempre lá dentro
agora é descansar por fazer guarda maior
com força em os modos usando tênis do
picolé
mas atenção no stream este furo
foi bastante cola e coloca o último
módulo por cima mas atenção os furos tem
que ficar sujo propostos para isso usar
e com quem faça o mesmo para o outro
lado
feito isso coloca os dois cliques modo
indicado e colegas foi uma escola e
coloca outro seguro por cima ora
importasse mais ou menos do tamanho o
coloca na parte da frente e outros
elementos acho que dá para trás atenção
isso não pode parar o movimento dessas
partes do arco agora foi outro dado em
cima até ficar tudo furos não cola e
coloca o outro circo por cima e agora
vamos juntar as duas partes com bastante
com mais atenção tem que ficar tudo para
alinhar um elástico um lado e do outro
faz parte do arco e para ficar mais
bonito usar aqui incluindo barba preta
para conexão do elástico com o arco
faço isso para os dois lados
já para o filho no ato simples que agora
carrega revista e centraliza o fio ou
estiver centralizado uma gota lugar
assinalado amanhã mais um crime cópia do
fio e qual empresa assim mas somente com
esta aparência
isso irá ajudar nos a carregar a classe
pouco mais facilmente
terminada a pista está na altura de
prendemos ela ao nosso brasil
por isso eu usei popular mas se vocês
quiserem podem usá velcro fita elástico
o filho da isso vai depender bastante do
vosso gosto e da disposição que vocês
tiverem por fazer oque é tão é uma coisa
se vocês quiserem perguntar ela convém
que vocês pintem as peças antes de colar
tudo ok porque você escolar em depois
como eu fiz
vai ser muito mais difícil e vai ficar
para aquecer pronto vocês vão ter muita
dificuldade em pintar e outras que nem
vão conseguir a ok pronta que já está
aberto e pintada não é a mesma mas é o
mesmo modelo é só porque o acordo já
está feito há uma coisa que você não
tenha parte quando vai ficar o vosso
braço porque quando tentaram você não
transpirar e vão ficar todos pintados e
prontos aos ganhos o fim os perseguem
gustavo se você escutar o mesmo deixe
voz shopping eu posso favorito e se
inscreva no canal que isto ajuda
bastante a divulgação ea punição do meu
trabalho e claro munição vocês podem
usar uma carrada de coisas
o importante é que vocês sejam
responsáveis e não disparem contra
ninguém e só ficamos por aqui a deus e
13 braço digital